[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si apple
une victoire spectaculaire c'est lui par
certaines des légendes du tennis comme
rod laver et billie jean king bien
qu'andré secoué la nouvelle vedette du
tennis féminin
andré secoué nez à nez slogan banlieue
de toronto de parents roumains
c'est là qu'elle est entrée au centre de
formation de tennis canada à l'âge de 11
ans depuis son ascension a été constante
puis fulgurant depuis l'automne dernier
du 243e au 24e rang mondial aujourd'hui
qu'elle a eu du grain a eu de la
détermination mais elle a eu un sérieux
coup de pouce de son entraîneur sylvain
bruneau qui a trouvé vraiment les bons
mots pour la motiver retourner sur le
terrain c'est une chose d'obtenir les
bons conseils
c'est une autre chose de les mettre en
pratique
je sais qui se bat extrêmement fort puis
elle va jamais abandonner près se pense
pas meilleures que d'autres même au
contraire elle est très humble puis est
très reconnaissante aussi de son équipe
de l'aide qu'elle reçoit puis après on
pas pour acquis
chacun des matchs qu'elle joue donc
c'est quand même phénoménal de voir ce
chez une jeune femme de 18 ans james
blake
le designer au tournoi de miami et
ancien quatrième joueur mondial l'a
considère déjà comme une vedette
elle a fait ce que les plus grandes
championnes ont fait pire pas de raison
que l ne soit pas la future numéro un
mondial dans quelques années il n'y a
aucune raison du comment ils jouent vu
ce qu'elle est en train d'accomplir
il faut il faut être vraiment ambitieux
pour elle et puis vraiment y croire très
fort
tiens station
à y bien cadré secoue son équipe
arriveront à miami seulement tard lundi
soir elle aura la journée de mardi pour
décompresser et trouver ses marques sur
les terrains floridien elle disputera
son prochain match seulement mercredi il
s'est entraîné et radio-canada miami